un carrosse en citrouille en ces
vacances de toussaint le château de
dampierre est passé à l' orange
des couleurs chaudes pour le début de la
saison froide c'est toujours un moment
un peu triste la brume le matin la pluie
et autres et donc il faut donner un peu
de lumière dans cette danse pendant ses
vacances il ya quelques taches orange
qui sont opposés à droite à gauche sur
le domaine pour mettre en valeur tout
cela mais c'est surtout sur l'automne
l'automne avec ses feuillages avec ses
marrons c'est châtaignier si l'on fait
le tour de tout le domaine on peut
revenir avec un panier de châtaignes on
peut revenir avec des marron d'inde
une visite qui se prolonge à la tombée
de la nuit citrouilles des décorations
s'illumine jusqu'au 3 novembre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à saint cyr l'école les citrouilles sont
aussi à la fête à la fois effrayante ou
amusantes
elles sont creusés par les plus jeunes
des ateliers seront proposés dès l'âge
de 5 ans la fête des citrouilles est un
grand classique des fermes de gally
après avoir cultivé 10000 citrouille
dans nos champs dans la plaine de
versailles on les a récolté ces
dernières semaines en atelier en
lui-même dur grosso modo une demi heure
mais durant ces journées on a les après
midi des représentations théâtre autour
de bien sûr de la citrouille de manière
à pouvoir faire en sorte que les
familles puissent passer un après midi
sympathique le 30 octobre la ferme
ouvrira pour la première fois en
nocturne une enquête où les équipes vont
chercher à vous faire frissonner